>> RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT IS
UNFOLDING.
>> OF COURSE I TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S HORRIBLE WHAT YOU SAW.
TO SEE PEOPLE TREATED LIKE THEY
DID, HORSES RUNNING OVER PEOPLE
BEING STRAPPED.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU, THOSE PEOPLE WILL
PAY.
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT THERE
WOULD BE PAYBACK LAST YEAR AFTER
IMAGES OF BORDER PATROL AGENTS
USING CLIPS CAUSE UPROAR AND
FALSE ACCUSATIONS.
DHS SAID THERE WOULD BE A QUICK
PROBE, SIX MONTHS LATER, THAT
INVESTIGATION IS STILL ONGOING
WITH NO INFORMATION RELEASED.
HERE TO REACT, ACTING DHS
SECRETARY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> YOU WOULD THINK THAT
INVESTIGATION LIKE THAT WOULD
TAKE MAYBE A WEEK, TWO WEEKS.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT HAS TAKEN SIX
MONTHS.
WE MAY NEVER KNOW THE RESULTS OF
IT, BECAUSE WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> WELL, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
AT THAT TIME IF YOU RECALL, THE
DHS SECRETARY SAID THE
INVESTIGATION WOULD BE CLOSED IN
A MATTER OF WEEKS.
WE ARE NOW SIX MONTHS, YOU KNOW,
NOT ONLY DOES THAT DHS
SECRETARY O AN APOLOGY THOSE
BORDER PATROL OFFICERS BUT ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT WHO MADE
DISPARAGING COMMENTS.
I'VE BEEN BRIEFED ON MANY OF
THESE TYPES OF INVESTIGATIONS.
IT SHOULD NOT TAKE SIX MONTHS
WHEN ALL THE FACTS AROUND VIDEO,
YOU HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS DOWN THERE ON THE
BORDER.
YOU CAN GET INTO AN
INVESTIGATION AND CLOSE IT
PRETTY QUICKLY.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO REVEAL
THAT THEY DID NOT DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
THE VIDEO SHOWS THAT.
EYEWITNESS ACCOUNTS SHOW THAT.
I DON'T THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO ADMIT THAT.
>> NEVER TOGGLE PHOTOGRAPHER WHO
TOOK THE IMAGES IN QUESTION SAID
NO ONE SAW BORDER PATROL AGENT
WHIPPING.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE THING, YOU
KNOW.
IT SHOULDN'T TAKE SIX MONTHS TO
HAVE THAT GUY COME OUT AND SAY
THAT.
SOMETHING ELSE WE WANTED TO PICK
YOUR BRAIN ON.
THAT IS COMING UP ON APRIL 1ST.
IT SOUNDS LIKE TITLE 42 IS GOING
TO END.
IT LOOKS LIKE AS MANY AS 170,000
REFUGEES COULD BE HEADING INTO
THE COUNTRY.
WHERE DO WE PUT THEM?
>> IT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
TITLE 42 WAS ALWAYS A TEMPORARY
MEASURE.
IT WAS ALWAYS GOING TO GO AWAY.
WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
DONE AS THEY HAVEN'T PLANNED FOR
IT AND THEY HAVE UP WITH OTHER
POLICIES IN PLACE TO DETER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES THAT WE SEE.
NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE THE AMOUNT
OF FOLKS THAT ARE COMING TO THE
BORDER EVERY MONTH, 170 --
8 MILLION.
WE ALSO HELD A SURGE THAT'S
GOING TO COME ONCE THE CARTELS
AND THE SMUGGLERS AND OTHER
START ADVERTISING THAT TITLE 42
HAS GONE AWAY.
IT'S A DOUBLE WHAMMY HEARD THIS
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD HAVE
PLANNED FOR THIS BETTER.
THEY SHOULD'VE PUT PROCEDURES IN
PLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THEY CONTINUE TO
DO AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE IT IS THEY
CONTINUE TO TREAT THIS AS THOUGH
IT IS A CAPACITY ISSUE.
IF THEY THROW MORE RESOURCES AND
MORE BODIES ADDED, THEY CAN
PROCESS THESE INDIVIDUALS BEST
OR.
THAT'S NOT ADDRESSING THE
UNDERLYING CAUSE OF THE ILLEGAL
BEHAVIOR AND THE PULL FACTORS
THAT ARE CAUSING A LOT OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO CONTINUE TO BREAK
THE LAW A MONTH MONTH AFTER
MONTH.
>> AFTER THEY ARE PROCESSED AS
WE ARE LOOKING RIGHT THERE IN
TEXAS, THAT THEY ARE RELEASED
INTO THE INTERIOR.
AND THEN, THEY ARE TOLD, COKE
QUEUE IN I.C.E. OFFICE.
OFTEN TIMES, THEY DON'T.
>> THEY HAVE BROKEN THE SYSTEM
ALONG THE BORDER.
IT'S OVERWHELMED.
IT WILL RELEASE INDIVIDUALS INTO
THE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T SEE THEM SHOWING UP.
WE KNOW THAT 80% TO 85% WILL
NEVER QUALIFY FOR ASYLUM.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FROM THE